but the other thing you share is quite
short-lived careers in modeling oh wow
so because you now what was your big
break was it focus choir I think all of
it talked about it or was it in fact yes
because he did you look at these like
it's hard to make a jumper sexy true
that but I think
I mean here's the thing sweater has
eyeballs still buy that and it's at the
point of that is you can learn to knit
it yourself so you guys can take one of
those home and knit it yourself I say
goodbye the sweater and then I have to
do it myself
yeah actually there's a classic thing in
here so you know you want something for
Christmas and you say to like your mommy
your granny so I'd really like a really
trendy sweat top I'd like a really nice
trendy zippy upset top and then they
knit it for you but you still do some
modeling don't you sporadically and very
unsuccessfully oh stop what I did do I
did some um I did a campaign for
Burberry which was very amazing and I
did a few years ago and Mary Testino
shot it and I remember doing it was when
I was just starting out and they were in
this photograph there was a sort of
there was a model and me an actor
wannabe actor and a musician and Meritus
Tino who I'd never worked with who is
one of the most extraordinary brilliant
people but he's almost in that moment he
was always like I said a parody of
himself so we had to run and jump for
the photograph and he goes he's
literally got the camera there and he
goes okay so darling your supermodel you
rock star Eddie you movie star I'm Mary
at the studio I wanted to go
these two sort of pros and me with this
[Applause]
he gets the photos because they're so
natural ones of sort of shock and minor
despair because you you don't have my
picture I'll tell you why yes tell us
wife is it really amazing doctor
Abercrombie model yeah hey I probably a
[ __ ] ladies gentleman you know don't
make your whose story so my pictures
never came out it did like the whole
campaign and the pictures never came out
and I don't know why am i agent wrote
and asked why and they literally only
responded with the photos they like
their whole like idea was like we want
real people so they you know they like
God I don't know we were like on a beach
and then they threw us a football and
they're like play football and all the
other models were like playing football
like in a pretty way you know like not
me
why with all of the photos I've got a
red face covered in sweat my nostrils
are flared
like at one point a girl yelled just get
her away from me scholarship to Kings
College
I probably shouldn't brag but Aragon
amazing astonished the problem is I got
a lot of brings but no polish I got a
holla just to be heard with every word I
dropped knowledge I'm a diamond in the
rough
I shine a piece of coal trying to reach
my goal my power of speech unimpeachable
only 19 but my mind is older these New
York City streets get cold
a shoulder every burden every
disadvantage I've learned to manage I
don't have a gun to brandish I walk
these streets famished the plan is to
fan this spark into a flame but damn is
getting dark so let me spell out the
name I am there yea DX again D er we are
meant to be a colony that runs
independently meanwhile Britain keeps
[ __ ] on us endlessly they tax us
relentlessly thinking jaws shows around
a rose a spending spree penny ain't
never gonna say his descendants free so
there will be a revolution in the
century and to me he says in parentheses
don't be shocked when your history book
mentions me I will lay down my life if
it sets us free eventually you'll see my
ascendancy and I am NOT throwing away my
shot but something like that
[Applause]
[Applause]
that matter what with Mike now Mike
might be a good companion trick for your
moving ears Mike can it says here
uniquely fold his tongue oh okay
so we're not nice and close to Mike's
mouth okay and and here we go Mike
folding is problems are they your own
teeth they are
[Laughter]
no yes not yet okay
in fairness you know professionals are
having trouble on this show I mean
Wolverine
[Applause]
audience very good
why didn't I think of that
you have a special thing to protect
because Emma - Emma Stone yeah she was
worried about you
well she was so Emirates David had to
finger me sort of avoid finding anything
that you shouldn't have because it's
sort of under the sheets like that and
she said little bit worried about it
don't worry don't worry I'm will I know
I know it so I asked makeup Titan if
they had a sponge and so I put Spanish
there the fungus sponge it was a big wet
Spanish story afterwards picture just
going up my leg and shoe it
[Laughter]
we're collecting people's special skills
we've seen some Marvis skills so what
might you delight if we're at a party
what would you delight people with I
haven't done it for a long time but I
used to do a Velociraptor impression
okay so what do you need anything for
this um maybe these shoes off okay
Jubilee help without it no no I do that
I can get them off it's you know the
famous scene where the Velociraptor is
looking for the children yeah oh yes in
the kitchens yeah oh yes I do know yes
yeah I kind of reenact that I mean be
kind to me imagine there's some children
that I'm running after and they're all
scared it's usually I'm doing that at a
party and there's lots of kids okay do
you need to jump on a table or anything
no I just need a bit of space this is
good excuse she's an actress just
explore the space
yeah it's good okay oh she's happy she's
happy out of the way no I'm okay here no
because you can be part okay okay we've
got a little bit of music little music
goodbye career
[Music]
[Applause]
very very talented
soon you'll be at the Oscars this will
be like a bad dream since this is my
money to you do we need room yeah you
need room oh yeah okay
so well any bit of the song dude no what
should they be I thought I'll give you
music okay you don't need feel free to
sing along
well do you know all of it you know
Oliver we don't need music you're good
doing it okay okay so basically the
dream was if you were 11 years old and
he wanted to be an actor I feel like
everyone in England at some point played
someone in Oliver and I wanted to be in
the gang and I only got the part of work
house point number 43 but there was I
did an audition I still remember the
dance and here's how it goes ba ba bum
BA bum bum ba bum BA bum cause
you've got all David Beckham you've got
met your match I just wanted to meet you
[Applause]
[Music]
you